hey guys how's it going I'm just and
today we're going to be going through my
amiibo collection I have been meaning to
do this video for quite some time but
this video is going to be extra special
because I'm going to be importing all of
these amiibo into Zelda breadth of the
wild and end up with is officially out
so to celebrate I'm going to get really
wild now I did this yesterday but you
can only use an amiibo once per day I
kind of ruin my chances of filming this
yesterday this time I'm going to take
documentation and we're going to see
what my inventory looks like because I
didn't do this yesterday so I have no
idea how many things I gathered I just
was seeing if this would actually work
and it does okay so here's my inventory
so out of all of these amiibo there's
one that I'm missing it
isabell summer outfit in a girl's you
really need to change you so
unfortunately I do have it somewhere in
this house but I've ripped everything
apart trying to find her and I can't
find it so unfortunately we're gonna
have to do without it if you would like
to follow along at home my friend Mike
made me this amiibo checklist I started
making this checklist very very early on
we mean evil first came out and it
became quite tedious Mike is incredible
graphic designer he does all of my
design stuff so huge thank you for
putting this together because I don't
think my patients would have liked just
putting this together again he's
included everything all of them even the
amiibo trading cards but yes also work
in Delta dress of the wild I was
collecting those for a while and then I
decided I got to draw a line somewhere
so this was where the line was drawn
wait a minute Rishon if you guys want to
download this you can have your own
checklist and again huge thank you to
Mike and if you're wondering why does
Leto sitting right there that's because
I was using black play-doh it's a whole
destroyed cotton place how that's going
to work I'm going to go through starting
over here with our original Mario from
the first series work my way around and
then last but not least we're going to
go over all of the Zelda's I'll import
the Zelda and you go last
I'd also includes the Zelda amiibo that
will release throughout the year now not
all amiibo are created equal all of the
Zelda need they'll give you higher
ticketed items you also get a chest
which will give you armor and extra
goodies that the rest of the amiibo do
not there's also a few throughout here
that also give you a treasure chest but
I don't remember which ones
going to buy it all together I guess
let's get started I don't know how this
is going to work out I have been
planning this for a very long time
I have half my controller over here and
the other half here so I guess we'll see
what happens and also I want to note my
television is extremely far away from
where I'm sitting right now I'm also not
going to pick up all my items and Billy
end so who wish us luck
my name is you disappearing just to be
sure here oh yeah arrows
[Music]
I'm gonna lose it
bye follow me a busy I don't we my
favorite amiibo to date in this
glow-in-the-dark goo amiibo
[Music]
the others definitely disappear if you
can really fast if you can't see my TV
so I know what's happening so it looks
like you could only have four on a
screen at the same time that's good to
know
with a little too late since I've
already done all of these ones kind of
hard when they're all piling up side we
I get the point
[Music]
have you know the high grass the PC will
do it you come again you know this is
exact you've already
why would like to try these are you to
placate that I have here and if I'm
actually dressed up like my friend Ed I
drew a beard on him though I already
imported to me
so I'm going to try and force this one
and see more it looks like it works
here's another princess really it's just
one thing to let me go they can be
duplicate characters ah
[Music]
we're going to pick it up all my items
go to ruin my family yeah buddy
I'll take that oh my god this is absurd
since we're really here for the Zelda
amiibo because that's where all the good
stuff is Wow and once I'm done with all
these all done evil that will get to
these cards because this is going to
take a little bit time
let's see what we got that part about
Rosella and you go you get fish easily
with Oh Armour that's not something it
isn't a sure what I'm wearing is that as
an aqua hey animo supporters campus use
triggers God won't that jingle oh wow oh
the wind I'll take the hem if you got
from the girl aha hold your shield okay
cool take it
[Music]
I mean honestly does any me know that
you're going to get you might as well
choose all the ones because they
definitely worth it
I'll tell you you need to Rafi here she
go
sapphire I'll take that as well might as
well in Portland is hopeless
amber yes please
time for link Rider we gotta get out of
this crap ice arrow well we're happy to
ocarina link let's do him now yeah
look at that oh my goodness I got a raw
cry me yeah yeah sir no oh if you don't
want had a chat
[Music]
I'm so busy right out there I just
wasted a whole day okay here's another
older link amiibo a hydro melon I don't
even have a those yet palm fruit yeah
mighty banana you give me some good
stuff Lee thank you
[Music]
30th anniversary
[Applause]
link oh oh oh yeah Ruby Apple Ruby Apple
bomb arrow hello
thank you for all those goodies but okay
this is Archer link so hey yes even that
hard salmon we got woof link sweet hop
look at all these people are just
praying through here
I have to book links that I guess I'll
get to save that for a later hmm
what did you give me meat meat meat meat
when I prime me - yeah you want that
prime you want that prime meat for sure
dragging bill was okay I don't like
doing it I actually would like that
black anomaly is the Guardian these
things are terrifying and I hate them in
the game absolutely hate them
[Music]
The Guardian dropped in which treasure
chest and also these little I guess you
can call them italic Foursquare they're
not sure if they have a proper game
oh those you can use your magnesia pick
those up oh sorry
get out of the way bro look
oh I'm so sorry hey you see a microRNA
YouTube video ancient core oh cool so
that's it for always develop an ebow
that just recently came out with breath
of the wild so if you're looking to
enhance your gameplay these are the ones
that you want that for sure and if
you're absolutely crazy like me and
decide who we're all of your amiibo make
sure you collect all your items after a
week's re-import I guess I should start
with heart do why not
we're here but also have to do today
besides it at this video by Zelda
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I wasn't prepared to fight clearly
are you kidding me oh gosh I think that
thank you sir
god bless you look sighs the last card
let's take a look at our inventory see
what we've got there are weapons
[Music]
so Konami a lot of meat well thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed this video I have a new Isabelle
on the way I also have the Monster
Hunter stories amiibo I've been holding
out on the Skylanders supercharging but
never play Skylanders before so I felt
like I didn't need to get those but now
that I'm sitting here doing a collection
video
I have almost the entire collection
except those is what's one of why am i
holding back anyway I'll see you guys in
some videos hopefully this week I'll
probably be playing a Zelda all weekend
so I'm not sure if I'll get around to
making any other videos maybe I will
will see also getting over a really
often cold I feel like I'm dying I will
say it's the best time to get sick
because not only am I actually fake but
it's an incredible excuse to do nothing
out with it feel better
playing video games read oh what a great
tripod save this for later this is a
great life act okay I know I said this
video was over but I forgot a very
crucial amiibo the huge
Yoshi woman evil my dog he's feeling
this I have to keep hiding those for my
dogs good to keep stealing in school it
me head over there by the couch so I
completely forgot about this
[Music]
I've been having a little business you
Maddie isn't set with the yarn Yoshi
amiibo and I can't turn it off of them I
can't baby back what's your specialty
Jenny you're Ashley there's Multan
together
leave it no no no he wasn't treat or you
want Yoshi here sit wait
[Music]
played on my way
phenom leave a sign below and you can
watch those after that one of the things
that I was most surprised about is the
support ability I mean yeah basically a
tablet of controllers but for me I play
so much too tender 3 dias I really don't
we home without it I love StreetPass
that is one things that this is lacking
currently I am holding the Nintendo just
has some